Dubrovnik is often called Croatia's most
beautiful city the port on the Adriatic
Sea has about 40,000 residents and is
the country's most popular tourist
destination magnificent buildings bear
witness to the city's long history it
was founded in the third century AD in
1979 unesco declared Dubrovnik entire
Old City District a world cultural
heritage site the city has inspired
artists for centuries that includes Maya
kovacevic a 33 year old painter who was
born here Dubrovnik is special because
it has a strong bond between the history
and culture when you pass the narrow
street you can see the different
architecture from different periods you
can see the lots of different foreigners
coming here and by that lots of
different cultures are meeting together
you can get a good overview of dubrovnik
by taking a walk along the top of the
city wall which runs for almost two
kilometers it's up to 25 meters high and
dotted with defensive towers and forts
most of these fortifications were built
in the 14th century at that time
Dubrovnik controlled trade in the
Adriatic an elevated walk around the old
city is well worth the time
people should come on the city walls
because they can see the different do
blowing from a different angle I like to
see the hidden gardens which you cannot
see when you're walking down the street
I like to see the red roofs which is
also the one of the theme of my
paintings the straddle is the district's
main street after an earthquake
destroyed parts of dubrovnik in 1667
those areas were rebuilt in a unified
baroque style
Maya kovachev inches studio is located
on a side street she studied painting at
the Academy of Arts and split about 230
kilometers away she shows her work at
galleries in Croatia and Italy but she
always returns to Dubrovnik the bronek
offers me a lot of Matisse as an artist
this is a city of my childhood the good
memories so I know lots of corners I
have in my head so when I come to my
studio I just put the canvas and imagine
that place I was being just a few
moments ago and I paint one of the most
important buildings in Dubrovnik is the
rector's palace built in gothic and
Renaissance styles in the 15th century
it used to be the seat of the city
government another late gothic and
Renaissance building is the neighboring
sponza palace where merchants once
gathered to do business right next to
the city wall is the franciscan
monastery beautiful colonnades surround
the cloister garden here the monks
raised herbs that they made into
medicines in the cluster pharmacy
the Aquatica here in franciscana their
husband a pharmacy here in the
franciscan monastery since the 14th
century special about it is that from
the beginning it wasn't just for the
monks it wasn't just for the city's
rulers it was for all of dubrovnik
citizens ala verga the public's surge
mountain Rises on the outskirts of the
old city you can reach his 400 meter
summit on a one hour hike or in just a
few minutes with the cable car
off the city's coast is the island of
lokrum monks settled the island as early
as the 10th century I like to come here
to the walk because the colors are
beautiful I find the difference between
the colors of the red roofs of the old
town and the blue water in the sky after
exploring the city many tourists relax
on banya beach with its view of
dubrovnik old city
you